j'adore Netflix je sais pas si vous
adorez Netflix le problème c'est que
Netflix c'est cher et on n pas toujours
envie de payer ou en tout cas on
voudrait payer dans des meilleures
conditions et bien aujourd'hui je vais
vous donner 10 astuces pour avoir
Netflix gratuitement ou alors presque en
tout cas vous allez éviter de payer
Netflix plein ballon et ça c'est quand
même vachement bien et je tiens à
préciser que toutes les astuces que je
présente ici elles sont 100 % légales il
suffit juste d'être extrêmement
malin Netflix je suis connecté en France
si je veux prendre un abonnement par
moi-même je vais le payer très cher
est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen de prendre un
abonnement depuis un pays à l'étranger
pour venir payer moins cher et ben
justement j'ai la solution et vous allez
voir franchement ça envoie du bois en
fait ce qu'il faut faire c'est vous
preniez un VPN réseau privé qui vous
permettra de vous connecter depuis un
autre pays moi ce que je vous conseille
c'est de venir vous connecter ici depuis
la Turquie donc là je me connecte
directement depuis Istanbul je laisse
mon VPN se connecté voyez je suis
connecté turquy là je vais venir me
mettre ensuite directement sur Netflix
alors là j'ai soit la version anglaise
soit la version turque je vais mettre en
anglais c'est un peu plus simple donc là
je suis bien connecté en Turquie si on
veut vérifier qu'on est en Turquie je
vais sur un site pour vérifier mon IP
donc là hop il vérifie vérifie que vous
êtes humain ouais je suis humain ça se
voit et là je vois que je suis connecté
directement en Turquie donc là tout va
bien donc comme je suis en Turquie et
bien je vais venir m'abonner donc
lorsque vous êtes dans votre partie
d'inscription vous allez venir choisir
votre offre et alors là regardez c'est
là où ça m'intéresse je vais pouvoir
avoir un abonnement 4K premium mensuel à
229,99 c'est de la Livre Turque
l'abonnement standard 1080p à 176,99
c'est de la Livre Turque également et
après j'ai l'essentiel moi je veux le
plus gros abonnement alors je me dis OK
22999 Livre Turque ça donne quoi je vais
sur google et je cherche conversion de
monnaie turque là ça me montre que la
Livre Turque elle fait 0,031 € et bien
lorsque je me mets en livre turque 229
et quelqu ça me donne 7 € d'abonnement
et ça vous le voyez c'est sur la formule
4K HDR c'est juste dingue ça me permet
de connecter quatre personnes du foyer
ça me permet d'autoriser six
téléchargements et ça me coûte en tout
et pour tout 7 balles sauf que voyez si
je vais virer mon VPN je me mets sur mon
Netflix en France je vais sur mon compte
gérer l'abonnement 19,99 € c'est donc
beaucoup moins cher ça vaut donc le coup
de venir se connecter depuis la Turquie
pour venir prendre un abonnement à
Netflix il se peut qu'il vous demande de
vous reconnecter à Netflix depuis votre
VPN mais comme ça au moins vous réalisez
des économies et c'est quand même
vachement plus
intéressant le forfait Netflix le plus
cher 4K et compannie c'est à 19 € et des
brouettes est-ce qu'il existerait pas
une solution pour venir toucher moins
cher éviter de vous faire ouvrir en deux
par Netflix alors oui justement la bonne
astuce c'est de venir choisir le bon
forfait vous choisissez soit de la 4K
vous allez payer 19,99 € par mois soit
vous venez prendre un abonnement à 13,49
€ par mois on va descendre en qualité
vous allez être uniquement en 1080 p
c'est mieux pour venir regarder sur une
tablette ou sur un smartphone comme ça
vous choisissez soit vous payez
quasiment 20 balles c'est cher je
reconnais soit vous payez 13,49 € et là
c'est tout de suite un peu plus léger
alors rassurez-vous j'ai plein d'autres
astuces qui vous permettront d'avoir
Netflix quasiment gratuitement quasiment
gratuitement même peut-être gratuitement
mais ça c'est un petit peu plus loin
dans la
vidéo est-ce qu'il existe ait pas une
solution pour avoir justement accès à
Netflix en 4K dans la meilleure qualité
pour le mettre sur sa télé on peut le
mettre sur une tablette mais on peut le
mettre sur sa télé aussi et surtout en
le payant beaucoup moins cher alors si
justement il existe une solution mais
pour ça vous allez avoir besoin d'un ami
l'idée c'est de trouver quelqu'un un ami
de la famille qui a déjà un abonnement
Netflix alors je sais pas si vous le
saviez mais jusqu'à il y a pas très
longtemps jusqu'à l'année dernière vous
pouviez partager votre abonnement
Netflix avec des potes sauf
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes géolocalisé
Netflix va se rendre compte que vous
vous habitez à un endroit et que la
personne qui a l'abonnement habite à
autre endroit et un moment elle va
bloquer vous aurez plus accès à Netflix
alors Netflix c'est plutôt des malins
ils sont dit on va venir faire payer à
la caisse la personne qui veut son
abonnement supplémentaire qui est lié
déjà un compte et qui va le payer moins
cher en fait je vous montre ce qui se
passe lorsque vous êtes sur votre compte
Netflix vous pouvez venir inviter un
abonné supplémentaire sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir venir payer
pour cet abonné supplémentaire sauf que
c'est quand même beaucoup moins cher là
je vais payer 5,99 € par mois pour un
abonné supplémentaire cette personne
elle aura accès à son propre compte et à
son propre mot de passe elle pourra soit
récupérer son profil existant pour avoir
accès à son historique de visionnage
soit créer un tout nouveau profil et
puis surtout elle aura accès à tout le
catalogue Netflix sur un seul écran à la
fois vous allez pas venir le partager
pour une famille vous n'allez pas avoir
tous les avantages si vous prenez votre
abonnement Netflix par vous-même par
contre vous allez pouvoir venir regarder
vos films vos séries en 4K directement
sur votre télé ou votre tablette mais ça
vous le voyez au tarif de
5,99 € par mois et ça c'est vraiment
mais vraiment un super bon
plan le problème c'est que si vous
n'avez personne dans vos amis ou dans
votre famille ou dans votre entourage
qui accepte que vous payez vous les 5,99
€ par mois alors il existe une solution
qui n'est pas gratuite mais qui va quand
même coûter beaucoup moins cher que si
vous preniez un abonnement par vous-même
Premium en 4K qui vous permet d'avoir
accès à un compte Netflix deux fois
moins cher enfin quasiment deux fois
moins cher en fait c'est le partage
d'abonnement quelquun vous ne connaissez
pas un abonnement Netflix qui paye 19 et
quelques par mois pour avoir accès à la
version 4K et qui peut avoir deux
invités et bien cette personne elle se
dit je vais venir monétiser mes 5,99 €
par mois je vais venir faire de l'argent
avec et la personne qui a besoin d'un
abonnement elle va payer moins cher pour
avoir accès à son Netflix en 4K HDR je
vous montre comment ça se passe en fait
vous allez sur des plateformes qui sont
spécialisées il y en a plusieurs qui
existent je vous le dis c'est pas du
tout un contenu sponsorisé vous avez
notamment plit.1 COM qui existe qui vous
permet de venir partager vos abonnements
alors il y a aussi Sher sub vous
choisissez il y a plein de services
différents je vous monre Split en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que vous venez
choisir directement ici alors pour la
personne qui veut partager son
abonnement elle elle a qu'à aller ici
elle choisit je suis en france et je
veux venir partager un abonnement par
exemple je venir partager mon abonnement
Netflix donc elle vient ici elle cherche
Netflix OK et elle va créer un partage
public donc là ça veut dire qu'elle dit
bon vous devez obligatoirement n Si et
ça ok j'ai compris j'accepte qu'est-ce
qui se passe et c'est là que c'est
intéressant elle considère que vous vous
payez votre abonnement Netflix 19 € et
quelqu par mois et vous payez un
abonnement supplémentaire 5,99 par mois
si vous en avez deux en fait ça vous
coûte 31,97 par mois avec trois
utilisateurs max il y a vous et il y a
les deux autres donc vous vous souhaitez
partager les deux places supplémentaires
que vous avez ça vous permet de
récupérer en tout 21 31 par mois en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que si vous vous
le vendez à des potes au coup de revient
vous êtes à 5,99 x 2 ça vous coûte en
réalité 11,98 sauf que là vous allez
venir les vendre 2131 2131 - 11,98 ça
vous fera gagner par mois 9,33 € et ça
vous le multipliez par 12 mois ça vous
fera gagner en tout quasiment 112 € à
l'année donc ça c'est un vrai bon plan
et ça va surtout réduire le coût de
votre abonnement ça veut dire que par
mois vous allez payer 31 vous allez
récupérer 21 ça vous coûtera un peu plus
de 10 balles pour venir payer Netflix
directement au lieu des 19 € et en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que la personne
elle va payer elle 10,66 € donc vous
avez de places 10,66 par 2 je vous
laissir le calcul était marqué tout à
l'heure ça c'est quand même vachement
bien la plateform elle elle prend une
commission ici de 1 € et le truc est
juste extrêmement pratique ça veut dire
que vous vous avez un abonnement Netflix
que vous prenez grâce à ce site là ça va
vous coûter 10,66
par mois pour avoir accès à Netflix en
4K HDR de façon complètement légale sans
AUC aucun problème et je vous mets les
liens dans la
description si vous souhaitez payer un
abonnement Netflix moins cher pas
gratuitement mais en tout cas beaucoup
moins cher il y a une solution qui est
extrêmement pratique je donne quelques
instants les solution pour l'avoir
complètement gratuitement mais là on va
regarder un petit peu le moins cher
pourquoi ne pas accepter de regarder un
peu de pub pour avoir votre abonnement
moins cher et c'est ce que vous propose
Netflix regardez moi j'ai une offre
aujourd'hui pleine patate à 19,99 mais
si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez prendre
un abonnement Full HD pour venir
regarder directement sur une tablette on
peut sur la télé mais la qualité elle
est pas folle folle même s'il y a de l'
scaling sur votre téléviseur c'est pas
fou fou et bien vous regardez ici
directement sur une tablette vous
acceptez d'avoir quelques posts
publicitaires et là vous le payez 5,99
au lieu de le payer 13,49 pour la même
qualité juste parce que vous avez de la
pub donc si la pub ça vous dérange pas
trop et si vous accepter d'avoir de la
pub vous allez toucher un tarif beaucoup
plus intéressant 5,99 par mois et ça
c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal alors je peux prendre un abonnement
directement Netflix je le vois mais je
vais venir payer soit un peu moins cher
soit en le partageant soit le payer
directement moi-même plein ballon mais
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas une astuce
pour venir prendre un abonnement Netflix
dans une offre tout compris comme ça il
y a Netflix dedans et est-ce que ça ça
existerz pas par un opérateur ça tombe
bien ouais bah oui j'ai fait M recharge
il y a deux opérateurs aujourd'hui qui
vous permet de venir prendre des
abonnements inclus directement avec
votre off box il y en a deux le premier
c'est Free qui a lancé il y a pas
longtemps sa free box ultra avec plein
d'abonnements inclus vous avez 280 chaî
vous avez en plus Disney plus inclus
standard avec de la pub prime inclus
vous vous avez canal plus inclu
directement et vous avez Netflix inclu
c'est la version standard avec la pub
qui coûte 5 € et des brouettes par mois
et Universal plus inclu alors
l'abonnement au niveau de votre box il
est quand même un peu plus cher on va
s'en douter mais il y a tout dedans il
coûte 49,99 € par mois pendant 1 an et
après ça coûte quasiment 60 balles par
mois sans engagement vous avez quand
même Disney plus prime canal plus
Netflix Universal plus et vous avez 280
chaînes inclues voilà dont la TV avec
Canal c'est assez énorme donc ça c'est
intéressant c'est la première offre et
le deuxième opérateur qui vous permet
d'avoir ça c'est SFR vous avez une offre
SFR fibre power à 29,99 € par mois
pendant 6 mois puis 39,99 € par mois
engagement ici par contre de 12 mois et
vous avez Netflix qui est inclu pendant
6 mois et après bon il vous le facture
5,99 € donc ça veut dire que toute façon
pendant 6 mois vous allez le payer parce
que vous avez un engagement ici mais
pendant 6 mois vous avez quand même
Netflix gratos et ça c'est pas
mal il y a l'abonnement par l'opérateur
bien mais tu aurais pas des offres par
des fournisseur de service de film comme
on dit ça identique à Netflix qui me
permettrait de l'avoir à un tarif
extrêmement maîtrisé et bien j'ai bien
l'impression queoui regardez ça c'est
une offre qui m'intéresse chez Canal
Plus canal plus CIN series qui est à
partir de 29,99 par mois et qui me
permet surtout d'avoir inclus dans
l'offre canal plus Apple TV plus Disney
plus standard Netflix standard OCS
paramon plus ensuite j'ai plein d'offre
canal plus les grands écrans les cinémas
les séries les sport 360 les doc les
kids cine plus Canal Plus series et ça
c'est cool parce qu'en fait vous voyez
j'ai Netflix ici qui est inclu dedans
avec deux utilisateurs en simultané
c'est l'offre standard c'est l'offre en
1080p mais je l'ai dedans et en fait je
paye 30 balles par mois et pour 30
balles par mois j'ai tout ça qui est
inclu directement ça ça vaut vraiment le
coup donc si vous voulez profiter de
films de séries etci et ça et ça 30
balles c'est vraiment
intéressant maintenant j'ai envie
d'avoir Netflix gratos j'ai envie de pas
payer Netflix j'ai envie d'avoir un
abonnement offert pour j'en sais rien un
mois 2 mois 6 mois 1 an et ça c'est
totalement possible je donc vous
dévoiler tout de suite l'astuce pour
avoir Netflix gratos vous allez voir
c'est vraiment bien Netflix a créé un
truc qui est très bien c'est la
possibilité d'offrir un abonnement
Netflix à quelqu'un si pour votre
anniversaire c'est pour votre mariage si
pour Noël vous ne savez pas quoi vous
faire offrir si des amis de la famille
votre tata votre maman votre votre papa
qui vous voulez vous Demandre qu'est-ce
que tu veux à Noël et bien je veux
Netflix je veux pas payer Netflix je
veux Netflix et bien vous les envoyez
directement sur netflix.com et on peut
vous offrir ici Netflix en illimité avec
une carte une carte cadeau en fait on va
pouvoir venir acheter soit en ligne soit
en magasin en ligne vous pouvez aller
par exemple sur Amazon et là vous
choisissez votre carte cadeau pour la
France bah oui pour la France ça do
exister dans d'autres pays mais là je
suis sur la version française on peut
choisir la tête de la carte bon Lupin ce
qu'on veut bon Netflix moi ça me va bien
on choisit le montant 25 balles c'est un
peu rare 25 balles on va pas très loin
50 balles 100 balles moi je veux pour
200 € soit par email soit par SMS vous
mettez le destinataire de la part de le
message la date d'envoi on peut le
différer en fait dans le temps jusqu'à
dans 1 an donc vous pouvez prévoir pour
Noël pour les anniversaires vous êtes
peinard et comme ça vous demandez à
quelqu'un qui vous aime de vous offrir
Netflix et là pour le coup vous avez
vraiment Netflix gratos alors regardez
il y a ça on peut l'acheter chez
Micromania et on peut venir l'acheter en
magasin également Carrefour laFnac
Micromania comme ça vous allez avoir
enfin Netflix gratos et puis le truc qui
est cool c'est que ça peut vous donner
une idée de cadeau pour un ami de la
famille savez pas quoi lui offrir vous
lui offrez Netflix il sera heureux
regarde Netflix gratos ça c'est quand
même un super
cadeau bon je veux continuer à rester
sur mon idée d'avoir Netflix gratos j'ai
pas envie de payer un abonnement est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas une possibilité qui
me permette de récupérer Netflix gratos
d'avoir Netflix chez moi sans rien payer
en comptant sur la générosité des autres
et ben si c'est possible si vous habitez
dans un immeuble et bien peut-être qu'il
y a un de vos voisins qui a un
abonnement à Netflix et qu'on peut aller
le voir pour qu'il vienne partager avec
vous le le mieux c'est d'avoir un voisin
qui est quand même assez proche
physiquement de vous je vous explique ce
qu'il faut faire si vous vous entendez
bien avec votre voisin de palier voisin
du dessus ou du dessous voisin de palier
c'est ce qui a mieux quand même et bien
allez lui demander ah dis-moi j'aimerais
bien avoir Netflix est-ce que toi tu
aurais pas un abonnement je peux te
rendre des petits services faut faire un
troc l'idée ici on se rappelle c'est
d'avoir Netflix gratos donc bon c'est
possible et bien vous allez le voir et
lui il va pouvoir venir s'il est
d'accord et bien c'est de se dire ok je
vais venir partager Netflix avec toi non
pas en prenant un compte supplémentaire
payant mais bien gratos comme si c'était
un membre de votre foyer et bien en fait
ce qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il vient
sur son Netflix il vous crée un compte
supplémentaire et bien comme vous allez
être identifié au même endroit
géographiquement Netflix ne verra pas le
problème comme ça vous allez pvoir venir
regarder votre contenu très facilement
gratos alors attendez vous allez me dire
ouais ouais mais attends attends attends
ça c'est aussi lié à l'adresse IP
l'adresse IP définit l'endroit
géographique mais si Netflix repère que
l'adresse IP n'est pas la même même si
je suis au même endroit est-ce qu'il
peut venir m'emmerder déjà d'une je suis
pas convaincu parce que vous pouvez
regarder Netflix chez vous sur votre
smartphone en 5g et pas être connecté au
wifi il y a pas de raison et s'il décide
de vous embêter et bien à ce moment-là
ce que vous faites c'est que Vous
demandez à votre voisin de vous
connecter une fois par mois à son Wii ça
fait beaucoup de voisin mais bon si vous
lui rendez de bons services en face
pourquoi pas vous lui demandez de se
connecter une fois par mois à son wifi
parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
si Netflix considère que vous n'êtes pas
connecté au même wifi il va considérer
que vous êtes en voyage que c'est donc
le même abonnement que vous avez le
droit de l'utiliser mais que vous êtes
juste en déplacement j'en sais rien à la
fac si et ça et ça vous êtes parti en
déplacement vous avez une résidence
secondaire bref il peut venir vous
embêter à ce moment-là il vous demandera
de vous reconnecter au moins une fois
par mois au Wii auquel est lié
l'abonnement sur lequel votre voisin est
en permanence vous prenez ces codes de
connexion vous vous connectez dessus
soit une fois par mois Mo ça pourquoi
pas en permanence comme ça en plus
d'avoir Netflix gratos vous aurez
internet gratos vous grattez beaucoup
mais pour le coup on pay rien et ça
c'est
pratique bon si vous trouvez aucun
voisin autour de vous pour vous filer
accès à Netflix gratos il veut pas
partager le Wii bref il veut rien
partager vos voisins sont des rats c'est
pas terrible et bien est-ce qu'il y
aurait pas une solution pour venir quand
même avoir Netflix dans votre smartphone
votre tablette ou votre ordi sans rien
payer en fait ce que vous fait c'est que
vous allez trouvé quelqu'un qui a
Netflix un pote un ami quelqu'un de
votre famille qui habite pas forcément
au même endroit vous sinon ça serait
quand même trop facile vous vous
connectez sur son Netflix il vous crée
un compte Netflix depuis chez lui il
vous crée un compte Netflix gratos et
vous vous connectez sur son Wii et vous
téléchargez un max de films et de séries
alors on est limité bien évidemment
c'est pas la solution miracle et vous
l'avez quand même gratos comme ça vous
regardez vos trucs vous êtes peinard
vous consommez vous revenez faire le
plein chez lui et vous repartez ça vous
permet d'avoir Netflix gratos c'est
peut-être pas la meilleure solution mais
reconnaissez quand même que c'est
gratuit et quand c'est gratuit c'est
quand même très pratique maintenant que
vous avez Netflix gratos ou presque
gratos il va peut-être falloir venir
faire attention à vos yeux parce que à
force d'avoir tous ces écrans dans la
gueule en permanence on peut venir se
faire mal ça tombe bien parce que je
vous ai fait une vidéo qui vous montre
les SEP erreur qu'on fait tous lorsqu'on
passe trop de temps sur nos écrans la
vidéo est là et croyez-moi elle pourrait
aussi vous rendre
service